bonsoir première édition du 7 8
politique sur tv fil pour cette saison
une saison qui ne manquera pas
d'actualité avec deux élections
d'envergure la présidentielle en mai
tout d'abord suivie des législatives
pour le mois de juin nous organisons
d'ailleurs plusieurs débats sur cette
antenne comme à chaque fois vous en avez
l'habitude pour le moment l'heure est en
tout cas aux primaires à droite et même
à gauche et c'est un député socialiste
que je reçois pour ce premier numéro
benoît hamon élus dans la 11e
circonscription il est aussi un ancien
ministre de françois hollande et il
espère pourquoi pas lui succéder nous
parlerons de son programme mais aussi de
l'actualité
et puis deux lycéens qui voteront pour
la première fois en 2010 est le posons
également à leurs questions ce sera face
à face sur ce plateau on sort benoît
hamon en ce moment est bienvenue
françois hollande va perdre la primaire
il y a une vraie lacune dans sa démarche
il n'y a aucun examen de conscience ce
sont vos propos rapportés par le figaro
fin septembre est ce que vous les
matinées aujourd'hui plus que jamais oui
je trouve que le président de la
république mais c'est toujours le
réflexe où c'est souvent le réflexe
quand on exerce le pouvoir est dans une
forme de déni par rapport à l'exercice
du pouvoir
tout ce qu'il a fait évidemment n'est
pas mauvais
qui pourrait dire cela mais il ya
incontestablement un échec sur les
questions d'emploi sur les questions de
pouvoir d'achat et on s'est rendu compte
que ceux qui avaient payé le prix plus
forts ont fait des sacrifices les plus
importants étaient souvent les plus
modestes et cet échec là il faut savoir
le reconnaître ne serait ce que pour
proposer autre chose et essayer de faire
en sorte que instruits par l'expérience
on mettre en oeuvre des politiques de
solidarité des politiques sociales et
politiques d'emploi beaucoup plus
efficaces qu'elles n'ont télévision
l'agente à la primaire concrètement il
va la perdre oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il la perdra je suis sûr je suis
évidemment il faudrait de 20 pour pour
être certains mais mais quand on analyse
à la fois les intentions de vote mais
surtout quand on voit ce qui est
l'aspiration des français à tourner la
page
c'est à dire en avoir ni nicolas sarkozy
ni françois hollande mais que des hommes
et des femmes de générations nouvelles
puisse incarner le débat politique
proposer des solutions qui correspondent
à notre temps et pas assez vieilles
solutions on va dire ou néo libérale ou
social libéral peu importe ses vieilles
recettes qui consiste à dire on met le
paquet sur les marges des entreprises on
espère que par ruissellement ça créera
de l'emploi était augmentera les
salaires ça ne marche pas depuis 20 ans
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
tourner la page
et il le fera avec beaucoup de confiance
et de sérénité parce que notre pays est
prêt et on verra ce que vous proposez
justement de cette édition va revenir
sur l'actualité à présent l'actualité de
ce mois de septembre et cette arrivée de
migrants de réfugiés qui inquiète les
maires notamment ceux des yvelines
lou sienne au concours de communes ou
des camps devraient être ouverts
prochainement de communes qui s'indigne
le reportage de florane parfait des
migrants accueillis dans les yvelines
la décision a été confirmée par le
préfet les maires du canton du chesnay
incluant bougival la celle saint cloud
rocancourt et louveciennes ont appris la
nouvelle vendredi matin ils ont tenu une
conférence de presse pour exprimer leur
position face à ce plan d'accueil à
rocquencourt
une centaine de migrants sera accueilli
pour une période maximale de deux mois
sur le site de l'inria
on est mis devant le fait accompli
il est évident que rocancourt ben déjà
100 migrants dans une commune de 3200
habitants
ça représente 4% de la population et on
estime que c'est déjà beaucoup et qui
sera difficile de cohabiter
de son côté l'ancien hébergera de façon
pérenne 100 à 200 personnes
une situation problématique pour la
commune en effet de l'amiante aurait été
détectée sur le site situé lui même
proche d'une discothèque
en plus de cela un projet d'aménagement
avec des entreprises devrait voir le
jour sur ce site de ville vers un lieu
inadapté pour recevoir autant de
personnes selon le maire si c'est pour
reproduire ce qui s'est passé à calais
ça j'y suis totalement enfin dans la
danse dans l'esprit j'y suis totalement
opposé en tout cas je suis fermement
opposé à l'installation d'un camp enfin
à caen deux migrants sur le site de
villevayre que ce soit 10 que ce soit
sans les problèmes de sécurité sont les
mêmes les deux maires opposés à ces
implantations obtenu du préfet qu'un
groupe de travail de concertation soit
mise en place
le plan d'accueil nécessite 400 places
sur l'ensemble des yvelines nous avons
jusqu'à je dirais fin octobre pour
éventuellement trouver des solutions
d'accueil de ces personnes si nous
trouvons pas la solution on nous
apportera la solution de nos fans les
migrants pourraient arriver sur le camp
provisoire de l'inria roque ont cours
dans les jours qui viennent
concernant l'ancien l'échéance est
prévue fin octobre début novembre
du côté de la population la colère
gronde une pétition a été lancée par la
ville de louveciennes celle de recours à
des jeux tenus 1300 signatures en
quelques jours démarche les maires qui
s'indignent qui est refuse en tout cas
qu'il faudrait plus de transparence sur
l'installation de ces migrants de ces
réfugiés sur leur commune c'est
difficile la solidarité c'est pas simple
de répartir l'effort de solidarité et on
voit moi je ne méprise pas l'inquiétude
qui peut être celle
de certains habitants de ces villes je
regrette l'instrumentalisation qui en
est faite par certains élus quand on
compare ce qui pourrait se passer à
louveciennes avec calais ya évidemment
pas de comparaison possible ou non pas
calais c'était une jungle des décors
dire de l'habitat improvisé avec lens et
une situation qui a dégénéré aussi au
fur et à mesure du temps donc même si ça
me faisait rire mccalebb du jour au
lendemain elle vous y allez les faire
apparaître ces personnes qui sont
éligibles au droit d'asile pour la
plupart sont aujourd'hui pour certains
dans une situation où ils ont le droit
d'être sur notre territoire donc le fait
est que si nous ne voulons plus agen gle
de calais il faut pouvoir trouver des
moyens de d'héberger ces personnes et de
le père lait sur l'ensemble du
territoire
l'effort qui est demandé aux yvelines
qui est un grand département est un
effort certain 400 personnes en
l'occurrence hors concours ça va être
solutions d'hébergement provisoire qui
justifie que là on pense on ça pèse sur
les conséquences qui pourraient être
celles pour la ville mais je le dis
c'est pas simple à solidarité et il
entend certains élus prêts à la
solidarité mais toujours très loin de
chez eux
j'observe qu'une ville comme celle dans
laquelle j'ai été élue celle de trappes
accueille depuis de nombreuses années en
dépit de sa grande pauvreté et la
concentration pauvreté de l'accueil de
personnes sans domicile fixe de réfugiés
de migrants et pour autant personne ne
s'en est ému ailleurs ne s'est pas dans
les mêmes proportions en tout cas on
parle pas de l'installation de camps
sont la ville de paris avait déjà
aujourd'hui des foyers d'hébergement de
personnes sans domicile fixe de migrants
de réfugiés et personnes et tout le
monde trouvait ça parfaitement normal
quand cet attrape c'est normal qu'en ces
temps dans d'autres villes ça l'est
moins c'est ce qu'ils génèrent aussi le
manque de transparence c'est le fait
qu'on voulait pas qu'ils arrivent à
parler de joncels on la laisse
absolument mais là les maires sont
légitimes a demandé des explications et
je salue la réponse qui est celle du
préfet qui est de dire écoutez on
reprend la concertation regarde quelle
manière on fait et on n'impose pas des
solutions en même temps maintenant
disons le vis-à-vis de ces réfugiés il
faudra trouver des solutions
il faudra que les yvelines comme les
autres départements prennent leur part
de l'effort 400 personnes à l'échelle de
ce département
ça n'est pas grand chose comme quand on
évoque le nombre de réfugiés qu'on
accueille sur le territoire français ça
n'est pas en proportion grand chose
quand on sait que la plupart quittent
les territoires en guerre la syrie
l'irak l'erythrée là où aujourd'hui on
meurt par dizaines par centaines et par
milliers on en revienne actualité un peu
plus local même si bien évidemment la
situation est dramatique l'actualité
locale ce sont ces mères en colère et
les maires sont en colère pas uniquement
à cause de l'accueil d'aider des
réfugiés et des migrants il ya aussi
cette hausse des impôts locaux dans le
département des yvelines plus 66 % pour
la part départementale de la taxe
foncière le président du conseil
départemental le justifie par la baisse
de la dotation de l'état l'état se
désengage et il faut donc trouver des
ressources pour pouvoir continuer ne
serait ce qu'à payer le rsa par exemple
les demandes sont plus en plus
nombreuses est-ce que là il n'ya pas
aussi pour aller au fond de la réflexion
une volonté du gouvernement de déplacés
l'impopularité en baissant d'un côté les
impôts au niveau national et en disant
aux communes et aux départements
desnoyers vous c'est vous qui allez
devoir augmenter et c'est vous qui
serait impopulaire vous écoutez là il
faut être très honnête vous savez trés
pas d'être socialiste béni oui oui mais
le discours qui consiste à dire
systématiquement convient de le faire
monsieur bédié mais plusieurs élus c'est
pas ma faute
augmente les impôts localement
départementalement c'est la faute de
françois hollande
tout ça ça a ses limites aujourd'hui
incontestablement la baisse des
dotations d'état impacte les capacités
d'action des départements et des
collectivités locales mais pas dans les
proportions qui sont celles des
augmentations d'impôts une ville comme
saint cyr l'école vient d'augmenter de
manière incroyable les impôts locaux
c'est injustifié votre quoi ça n'est pas
justifiable pour la baisse des dotations
de l'état
ça va bien au delà à raison d'une
mauvaise gestion donc aujourd'hui d'un
certain nombre d'élus locaux qui en
profitent pour augmenter ou alourdir
lardoise de leurs habitants et de leurs
citoyen explique aux c'est la faute de
françois hollande alors moi j'utilise
d'appliquer aussi du côté de saint cyr
le maire de saint suaire est pas ce que
vous expliquez que c'est une mauvaise
gestion oui mais vous trouverez blesse à
la supériorité pour trouver que ça n'est
pas très sérieux et que en l'occurrence
on peut considérer qu' il ya eu des
choix politiques qui sont des choix
politiques critiquable en matière de
baisse des dotations aux collectivités
locales
mais ces baisses n'ont rien à voir et ne
justifient pas l'augmentation incroyable
des ogres des impôts locaux sinon pardon
le comparant des communes de taille
identique augmenterait de mai la même
manière les impôts autour par exemple de
saint cyr l'école est ce le cas c'est le
non humain pas aussi nul même pas c'est
parce que saint cyr l'école à spa c'est
qu'on soit avec donc minority vous
reconnaîtrez que là on peut comme on est
en capacité de comparer et à des sites
des communes qui avaient des situations
sociales difficiles des investissements
assumé qui n'ont pas fait ce choix
donc à un moment faudrait pas que telle
ou telle mère tel ou tel président du
conseil départemental considère qu'on
peut tranquillement envoyé la note aux
habitants de sa ville en dix ans de la
part de françois hollande
en l'occurrence qu'ils assument et qu'il
signe monsieur bédié qu'il signe en bas
c'est sa note monsieur de bain qu'il a
su qu'il y ait en bas c'est sa mère
faisait le président si vous la
remporter cette primaire tout d'abord
appelé ensuite la présidentielle vous
continuez la baisse des dotations
non je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est
parfaitement absurde aujourd'hui de
faire reculer les services publics donc
baisser les dotations parce qu'on doit
respecter un critère aussi souk
inefficace qui le critère des 3% de
déficit on voit que ça fait de
l'austérité ça ne fait pas de croissance
et ça ne fait pas d'emploi il serait
peut-être temps qu'on se rende compte
que cette politique a échoué là encore
c'est pour ça que je dis au président de
la république
changer de politique voyons je peux
aussi dire à l'endroit de françois
hollande qui a des choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas mais lui lui met sur
les épaules mettre sur les épaules de la
gauche des choix de groodt à sion
d'impôts qui sont d'abord imputable à
des municipalités à des départements
voilà je veux dire il a les épaules
larges mais on les lui fait un peu plus
leur voler à son secours
je pense que c'est quoi c'est juste il
faut le faire moi je
je suis pas pour que je me réjouissais
je vais vous dire que le département et
je le reconnais que maintiennent les
crédits pour les établissements et la
politique de l'intégration des personnes
en situation de handicap je le faisais
publiquement cet après midi donc je peux
dire moi quand ça marche
y compris quand c'est fait par monsieur
bédié mais quand on en rajoute
ben je dis qu'on en rajoute voilà
j'essaye d'être honnête avant
d'accueillir dans un instant de jeunes
qui voteront pour la première fois en
2010 est je vous propose de regarder un
dernier sujets liés à l'actualité cela
concerne la lutte contre la fraude dans
les transports une action qui est porté
par la région fossier j'ai aussi mais
dans l'opposition
écoutez ce reportage la chasse aux
fraudeurs est lancée avec la
promulgation de la loi dite leroux
savary du 22 mars 2016 est inspirée des
propositions de valérie pécresse
le cadre se durcit pour les fraudeurs en
2015 la ratp a comptabilisé 1 25 million
d'infractions 510 milles et pour
transilien
moi je trouve de tout le temps je me
serais pas attraper ans mais bon c'est
pas trop risqué de fraude et parce qu'il
n'y a pas tant que ça de contrôleurs
dans les bus donc au final n'en ce pas
risqué frauder pas s'y risquer les
transporteurs veulent prouver le
contraire
la loi le roux savary punit déjà la
déclaration de fausses identités de deux
mois d'emprisonnement et de 3750 euros
damende le délit dit d'habitude lui ait
relevé plus de cinq infractions sur une
année et le fraudeurs s'exposent à six
mois d'emprisonnement et 7500 euros
damende d'autres dispositions entreront
en vigueur prochainement
aujourd'hui les personnels de la ratp de
la sncf seront tous assermentés pour
contrôler et on pourra aussi avoir des
patrouilles en civil d'office de
sécurité sur le réseau ratp sur le
réseau sncf la loi a changé et ça va
devenir beaucoup plus difficile de
frauder et surtout ça va être beaucoup
plus pénalisant parce que si vous aller
quelque part et qu'on vous retient
plusieurs heures pour que vous prouviez
votre identité
eh bien ce sera difficile
des mesures censées faciliter le travail
des agents sur le terrain
le fait de communiquer sur ce nouveau
délit
de faire savoir qu'il se soustraient aux
contrôles peut entraîner une peine de
prison une peine d'amendé importantes a
évidemment un effet dissuasif
on aura toujours besoin d'un renfort
mais c'est vrai que vous avez beaucoup
de voyageurs qui ne présentent pas à
leur place d'identité qui ne veulent pas
la présenter et c'est vrai que c'est
assez accidentogène chaque année la ratp
consacre 1250 agents et 90 millions
d'euros à la lutte contre la fraude pour
le stif la ratp et la région ile de
france
l'enjeu est avant tout financier nous
avons demandé à la ratp de faire 20
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
supplémentaire grâce à la lutte contre
la fraude et à la cncs de faire 10
millions c'est des objectifs très
ambitieux en 2015 la cour des comptes a
évalué à 366 millions d'euros le coût de
la fraude en ile-de-france la lutte
contre la fraude dans les transports et
plus globalement la politique menée par
valérie pécresse dans la région vous qui
siégeait aussi mais dans l'opposition
vous en pensez quoi bon lutter contre la
triche c'est bien les lois sont faites
pour être respectées il faut pas aussi
précipité des gens les oblige à tricher
parce qu'on diminue toutes les aides qui
permettent le transport quand on
recherche un emploi quand on veut se
déplacer en ile-de-france dont moi je
suis attaché à ce que la solidarité
permettent aussi la mobilité et que les
plus pauvres les plus modestes puissent
se transporter partout surtout quand on
est à la recherche d'un emploi mais
sinon je ne peux pas désapprouvé le
principe selon lequel on cherche à faire
respecter la loi dalo est la même pour
tous et il faut qu'elle soit respectée
voilà on va s'arrêter là pour la partie
liée à l'actualité et donc ce sont deux
jeunes du lycée emilie de breteuil à
montigny le bretonneux qui nous
rejoignent en plateau
tout au long de l'année viendront en
plateau il nous le livrerons aussi leur
regard sur cette campagne ses campagnes
aussi bien présidentielles que
législatives ce sont les élèves de
terminale es du lycée millet breteuil à
montigny le bretonneux ils suivent d'une
spécialité sciences sociales et
politiques dont soit à inez et mons en
racontant bonsoir à tous les deux et
vous avez des questions à poser à benoît
hamon tout d'abord concernant la
précarité chez les jeunes
quentin en france la précarité touche en
priorité les jeunes 22 5% des jeunes
vivent avec moins de 960 euros par mois
quelles sont vos solutions pour la
jeunesse le revenu universel d'existence
des la majorité jusqu'à la fin de votre
vie
le principe c'est que chacun puisse
bénéficier d'un minimum qu'il soit qu'il
travaille qu'il ne travaille pas qu'ils
puissent compléter son revenu ou lui
servir de revenus quand on est par
exemple étudiants quand on cherche à
créer une entreprise qu'on a besoin d'un
filet de sécurité quand on a un
intermittent et qu'on a une situation
qui qui peut évoluer quand on a un
travail vous êtes vous aurez des
parcours professionnels très différents
de ceux de vos parents vous allez
probablement changer souvent de métier
c'est ce qui se prépare aujourd'hui je
suis favorable à ce revenu universel
d'existence comme une garantie qui offre
justement un moyen de lutter contre la
pauvreté mais surtout un moyen de
changer de relations au travail de
pouvoir choisir un temps partiel parce
qu'on sait qu'on a un revenu d'existence
à côté de son salaire ou de rester à
temps complet mais qu'on retrouve de la
liberté et du de l'autonomie du quand on
est jeune on a souvent l'impression
d'être assez contraint pas très autonome
c'est valable cantona au lycée mais vous
verrez c'est valable après dans
l'enseignement supérieur et ce revenu
universel d'existence et pour moi la
réponse fut très heureux de voir que le
sujet montrent beaucoup qu'il fait
aujourd'hui c'est la question sociale
centrale nantes on discute dans la
campagne présidentielle et les salaires
si je vois l'interrompt il ya toujours
une inconnue c'est le financement aux
situations que vous même vous dire que
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui à financer tout
ça va dépendre largement de l'impact qui
sera celui du robinet par universel
d'existence par exemple sur les salaires
parce qu'il va contribuer à baisser les
salaires ou va-t-il contribuer à raison
de la raréfaction du travail à
l'augmentation des salaires donc on a
des scénarii de financement qui vont
changer mais c'était la clé bah oui
c'est d'abord une redistribution des
aides existantes et comme vous le
distribuer ce revenu
universel à tout le monde même ceux qui
n'étaient pas les plus pauvres du plus
riches aux plus pauvres
defacto il va falloir repenser la
fiscalité individualisé l'impôt sur le
revenu repenser le financement le des
niches fiscales
probablement reconstruire une fiscalité
écologique
là où des entreprises tirent profit de
l'exploitation de ce qu'on appelle bien
commun l'air l'énergie l'eau où il ya
évidemment beaucoup de solutions qui
sont possibles et j'y travaille de façon
à ce qu'on ait une solution qui soit une
solution solide mais en même temps
reconnaissant que cette proposition
relève quasiment d'une révolution
équivalente à la sécurité sociale
c'est la création d'une nouvelle
protection sociale mais elle répondrait
très concrètement aux problèmes de
précarité n'est ce qu'ils sont
convaincus que quand on est convaincu
sens est revenu ce sera une bonne chose
ça n'arrêtait pas de discuter pour le
convaincre totalement
inès une question politique peut-être
sur le rassemblement de la gauche
oui parce que bonjour est-ce qu'on peut
pas cacher que les électeurs de gauche
ont déçu par le mandat de françois
hollande
comment est ce que vous feriez pour
reconquérir leur coeur et convaincre
ceux qui hésitent
je pense que quand
votez à gauche traditionnellement voté
pour deux raisons la justice sociale
d'égalité c'est que ce sont ces moteurs
la générale qui déplace les lecteurs
vers les bureaux de vote et il faut
mettre un bulletin de vote dans l'urne
c'est là-dessus effectivement vous avez
est assez lucide que le présent la
république a déçu c'est là dessus je
pense qu'il faut que la gauche
redevienne identifiable et beaucoup plus
clair qu'elle ne l'est incontestablement
quant à travers la loi travail on va
contribuer à faire baisser le tarif des
heures supplémentaires sert à faire
moins bien payés le travail des gens qui
avaient voté à gauche disent mais
attendez c'est le contraire de la
promesse qui était celle de la ville ont
fait le sale boulot de la droite
exact non mais je suis d'accord avec
vous et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut qu'on revienne à ce qui est
l'essentiel de la promesse de la gauche
c'est à dire l'égalité et la justice
sociale vous savez par exemple moi je
milite en tout cas je défends l'idée que
demain à côté de revenu universel
d'existence on reprenne le chemin du
partage du travail et de la réduction de
temps de travail c'est d'avoir des
métiers dans lesquels je sais pas ce que
seront nos métiers on va voir des
opportunités formidables grâce à la
révolution numérique et des robots des
algorithmes vont se substituer aux
hommes on parle maintenant pendant
quelques mois sinon quelques années que
dans les grandes surfaces quand vous
ferez vos courses ça sera pas simplement
des casses individuel il va y avoir des
portiques ou votre caddie vous allez le
passé et tout ce qui est dedans va être
scannés même plus besoin de caissière
une fois que vous avez payé les portes
s'ouvrent à vous passer il ya plein de
métiers dans lesquels ça va peut-être
améliorer notre vie de consommateur mais
là où il y avait une personne en face de
nous alors a disparu on aura plus
d'emplois
donc il probable que le travail se
raréfient faut aussi anticiper les
secteurs dans lequel on aura besoin de
plus de travail pour le soin aux
personnes a prise en charge des
personnes âgées notamment
mais à côté de cela je pense que le
partage et on travaille la réduction du
temps de travail est une des solutions
pour continuer à créer de l'emploi et
essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
moins de chômeurs ordonne à beaucoup
pointent au chômage
il ya des gens qui sont au travail
heureux mais aussi beaucoup qui quand
ils s'entraînent ils sont malheureux
c'est pas normal qu intel césure c'est
sur ce terrain là à mon avis qu'on
attend la gauche est pas
le fait de reprendre les solutions donc
comme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs très
bien convenu le sale boulot de une à
droite une toute dernière question va
être pris par le temps vous si vous
aviez chacun une question justin est
pour pour conclure vous avez une
dernière interrogation à formuler très
rapidement pour qu'on puisse avoir
quelque temps ensuite oui c'est une
question un peu plus philosophique en
gros si vous étiez président et vous
ayez un pouvoir de faire passer de
réforme qui sera incontestable lesquels
ça serait moins président à quand j'ai
engagé un peu plus du manga gérer je le
redis ce revenu universel d'existence et
pour moi centrale c'est une
ce n'est pas une allocation de plus
c'est vraiment le changement complet de
notre relation au travail y la deuxième
réforme que je mettrai en oeuvre à coup
sûr âge en aurez plein d'autres mais
c'est quand même le passage de la vème
république à une sixième république
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est dans
une démocratie par intermittence quand
on vote assez peu de pouvoirs que ça
change mais on ne fait que voter est
entre temps vous passez des lois même si
elles sont minoritaires et impopulaires
on ne peut pas révoquer un président de
la république on ne peut pas participer
à l'élaboration des lois pense que grâce
justement nouvelles technologies on doit
pouvoir donner davantage de pouvoirs
démocratiques aux citoyens et cette
forme de délibération qu'on n'a pas moi
j'y aspire donc le revenu universel
d'existence et la sixième mois merci à
tous les êtres venus en vous retenir
savait qu'à votre classe du lycée élite
bouteille régulièrement pour ce 7,8
politique merci à vous ces briques
on passe à la dernière séquence de ce
set 8 politique on va parler de votre
parcours ambitions très rapidement et
puis de ce programme sur tout mais tout
d'abord regardé et écouté cet extrait 7
à la fin de l'an de votre discours dans
de vos interventions
à
quoi sé sa nou lé vous faire remarquer
parce que je vais traduire les paroles
de ce morceau de ce mort vous allez mais
je vais traduire leur france peut-on
revenir pesons plus peut-on revenir
c'est le moment ce soir et le soir on se
battra jusqu'à ce que ce soit fini on
lève les mains en l'air comme s'il la
trompe pour l'état nous prions nous
inspire c'est forcément un an qu'ils
rencontrent dans une campagne
présidentielle c'est pas anodin aussi
c'est une musique plutôt jeune oui mais
ces jeunes parce que bon bah
parce que gentil et de l'énergie moi je
crois et l'électorat que vous voulez
c'est lui je crois dans une république
métissée moi je crois dans les forces de
la france j'aime parce ce visage un peu
égoïste uniforme qu'on veut nous nous
servir d'une france de gaulois moi qui
suis d'origine celte
par mon père ma mère mes grands-parents
donc vraiment de faisant mon arbre
généalogique je trouvais guère de traces
d'autres choses que des celtes j'ai
beaucoup de fierté mes origines mais en
même temps j'ai pas une vision statique
et immobile de mes origines et j'aspire
à vivre dans la france telle qu'elle
s'est toujours construite comme une
république qui s'ouvre est accueilli une
nouvelle génération de nouvelles
catégories de population et des forces
grâce à cela et donc c'est pour ça que
oui ce serait une campagne assez
énergisantes énergisante c'est comme ça
qu'on va là qu'on voit la qualifier
optimiste parce qu'il faut être
optimiste aujourd'hui optimisme dépasse
l angoisse identitaire oui ça fait
partie des points importants de votre
programme
mais c'est quelque chose que je méprise
pas non plus hein quand une femme me dit
qu'elles se sentent agressés parce
qu'une autre femme porte le voile je
m'interroge je me dis les possibles
n'est pas comme ça devenu raciste
islamophobe j'essaie de réfléchir quand
une femme décide de porter du racisme
pour autant d'être interpellé en tout
cas nous on verra je vous dit mords moi
le nom a nommé général mérite pas autant
à oyonnax mais mes pouvoirs des rendez
vous pouvez avoir des des musulmans
raciste dénombre film raciste le racisme
c'est pas juste là que l'apanage d'une
catégorie de la population c'est hélas
quelque chose d'assez bien partagée et
l'intolérance aussi mais je m'interroge
aussi sur qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une
femme désire pourra raison de sa foi
porter le voile et je leur ai je
respecte ses choix là après il ya des
règles et les lois de la république et
je pense que ces lois de la république
jusqu'ici il avait permis aux uns et aux
autres de vivre ensemble mais il ya une
forme d'hystérie aujourd'hui du débat
politique qui trouve dans
chaque prétexte aujourd'hui utilisée à
vouloir montrer du doigt tel ou telle
catégorie de la population
je pense que chaque fois qu'un
responsable politique fait d'une
catégorie de français sa cible et sa
cible principale
à raison de ce qu'il est de ce que les
gens sont je pense que c'était très
dangereux et jeu oui je crois que la
question sociale
combien je gagne mon travail est ce que
je choisis mon horaire de travail est ce
que je peux vivre avec un contrat de
travail qui est précaire toutes ces
questions sont des questions centrales
comme l'accès aux soins comme voyager
dans un esat aujourd'hui à trappes
on inaugurait une nouvelle structure ce
que font les familles les aidants autour
des personnes en situation de handicap
ou retour des personnes qui vieillissent
et sont dépendantes qui se préoccupe
vraiment du statut de l'aidant de quelle
manière accompagner ces français qui
aujourd'hui ont du mal
s'ils n'ont pas d'argent à pouvoir
prendre en charge quelqu'un de leur
famille qui devient dépendant ou un
handicap s'est questionné sur les
questions centrales on en parle très peu
dans le débat politique et j'ai préféré
qu'on parle de ça que de l' angoisse
identitaire de nicolas sarkozy christian
estrosi ou marine le pen même si
derrière cette question identitaire il
ya cette question de radicalisation elle
est elle aussi parce que vous citez
cette ville de trappes et il ya des
jeunes de la ville de trappes des moins
jeunes aussi qui sont radicalisées
l'équipe la vie qui partent en série de
recettes ya ce phénomène cet islam
identitaire qui s'est développé je
constate aussi qu'il ya 25 % des gens
qui votent front national
donc c'est une forme aussi de
radicalisation politique je constate
tout ça et je vous je vois dans dans
l'existence de ces phénomènes des
sources de tension de problème de
conflit et de violence plutôt que la
possibilité qu'on règle quoi que ce soit
donc c'est pour ça que je veux être
optimiste parce que je vois sur ce
territoire
beaucoup de raisons d'être optimiste
confiant dans l'avenir et pas simplement
rabougri
vous savez ranieri n'a comme ça gnagna
il nous reste deux minutes
malheureusement c'est très court il ya
deux questions que j'aimerais encore
vous posais déjà abrogé la loi travail
oui non vous avez déjà travaillé
puisqu'elle est aujourd'hui mauvaise
pour les travailleurs salariés et de la
dernière question concerne vos
différents mandats parce que on va quand
même le rappelez vous êtes conseiller
régional vous êtes député vous avait
siégé à la ville de trappes vous avait
siégé à l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
là vous êtes candidat pour cette
primaire de la gauche
si vous n'arrivez pas au bout de cette
primaire vous serez candidat aux
législatives
oui mais bon je préfère être président
de la république pour commencer un
combat après deux hommes et 7,6 à
sérieusement je m'engage chico je
m'engage c'est aux primaires ça je
pourrais citer les résultats des
sondages actuellement vous avez que vous
êtes crédité de 16% parmi les
sympathisants sympathisants de gauche
oui ça m'a aidé c'est un bon départ oui
honnêtement honnêtement
franchement je fais partie des 3 les
candidats potentiels il ya françois
hollande qui pourrait si arnaud
montebourg
oui voilà et 16 % oui c'est un bon
départ et c'est même un excellent départ
mais bon on n'arrivait pas à me faire ce
retard et vous est ce que vous serez
candidat aux législatives
écoutez franchement je vous réponds le
jour où il ya le résultat de la primaire
échanges aucun état d'âme et un deuxième
partie de la question est ce que vous
serez candidat aux législatives sur six
jeunes mon inscription d aimer oui oui
parce qu'il se dit ici que vous cherchez
à faire le meilleur score possible que
j'ai battu la dernière fois qu'il le
dise il se dit aussi qu'ils ont cherché
à venir un toxique
je vais quand même aller jusqu'au bout
de faire le meilleur score possible dans
cette primaire pour ensuite être en
mesure de négocier une circonscription
que les accepter est ce que c'est le cas
oui ou non répondit la réponse est
clairement non
si je dois être candidat aux élections
législatives quelque part après si je
perdais les primaires ce sera dans la
10e circonscription des yvelines que
chacun le sache et s'y préparent et bien
voilà c'est dit merci benoît hamon on
nous refermons 7,8 politique rendez vous
fin octobre avec un nouvel élu mais
d'ici là et dès le 14 octobre ça au
parlement européen le 7 il 7,8 politique
partir une fois par mois à la rencontre
des élus qui siègent à bruxelles et à
strasbourg au rendez vous qui sera
préparé par nicolas kirillovitch à très
bientôt sur tv fils